I am still shocked about this I am I am
so shocked I may fall out of my chair as
we play you this video on CNN of all
places they had this guy by the name of
Scott Jennings and he actually told the
truth
what's amazing to me that how little
Kamala Harris apparently has to do this
she can read something on Twitter one
day and be on an airplane the next to
make uh something literally out of
nothing this is a completely made up
deal
I looked at the standards I even looked
at an analysis of the standards and
every instance where the word slavery or
slave was used I even read the statement
of the African-American Scholars that
wrote the standards not Ronda Santos but
the scholars everybody involved in this
says this is completely a fabricated
issue and yet look how quickly Kamala
Harris jumped on it so the fact that
this is her best moment a fabricated
matter is pretty ridiculous in my
opinion you know this is what I'm trying
to show you is the Playbook that these
people use if you do anything right
DeSantis was coming for the gays and
then he was coming for a trans and now
he's coming for black people and you
know these things are all lies right
this is the freest most flourishing
state in the Union
[Music]
foreign